you made it you made it you made it oh
yeah you made it
it you made it weird with
petees what's happening weirdos this is
my incredible conversation with the
incredible Steve O who has a new special
out now called The Bucket List you can
find out how to watch it on Steve O
.c you can also come see me I'm doing
some standup coming up uh Tempe Arizona
for New Year's and then I will be at the
Brea Improv in California and we did
find new dates for Chicago uh apologies
again for rescheduling that guys that
was a hard one for me um but all of
those tickets are available on Pete
holes.com also my special is on Netflix
right now please watch that if you
haven't already it's called Uh I am not
for everyone and that is streaming on
Netflix right now uh what else I guess
we could talk about the pizza pics Pizza
picks as you guys know I only do ads for
things that I actually use and actually
love and obviously modern mammals is a
huge one for me I never used to wash my
hair I hated washing my hair cuz shampoo
sucks shampoo sucks so there's a real
problem with shampoo you wash your hair
I guess it's clean but it looks like a
bail of hay that you just took out of
the dryer it's crisp it's fried it's
fluffy it looks like crap so you end up
putting more crap in your hair just to
make it look natural again it was a
disaster so for years I just wasn't
washing my hair and then I found modern
mammals modern mammals in a nutshell is
shampoo basically that cleans your hair
so it's clean comb goes right through it
it's amazing but it doesn't dry it out
it looks like it looked before you wash
it in the sense that it's still natural
still maintain some of that oil some of
that H I don't know how to describe it
it basically looks like you have a
little product in it after you washed it
and you're ready to go I mean I've been
on red carpets and I washed my hair with
modern mammals that morning I never used
to do that but of course you have to
clean your hair so this is a huge
problem and this is the solution modern
mammals Game Changer it's got 40,000
guides have switched to it instead of
traditional shampoo the reviews are
mindblowing once you use it you will be
hooked for life I am hooked for life you
can't go back get a guy in your life
modern mammals maybe this holiday season
it's a wonderful gift they might not
even know they need it but you know they
need it it's a small Grassroots punk
rock company I love these guys and they
are saving our hair making this new
shampoo alternative specifically for men
they have bars for no plastic and no
fragrance or bottles it's like a magic
gray mud and I love the feeling of it I
love the smell of it and I love that it
gets you hair perfect every single time
in 6 seconds go to Modern mammals. comom
slwe where people can get a special
combo deal and try both the bottle and
the bar for both uh for $44 you get both
and support the show modern mammals.
momir we also brought To Us by our
friends at open you guys know I struggle
with sleep I struggle with anxiety I
have a brain that's very active it's
very hard to turn it off it's hard to
calm down and settle my mind I got a lot
going on up there well thankfully I
found a new Solution that's been working
wonders for me the open app which takes
you through thoughtful and intentionally
designed classes for clarity you can
hear Leela in the background anxiety
Focus energy and sleep the difference
between before and after for me like
like before the calming breath work
class is night and day I'm a huge fan of
breath work but it's not always easy to
do you need help I need guidance and I
want to make sure I'm doing it right and
the open app takes care of all that I
actually like to do it before I go on
stage to feel a little more centered and
clear and get rid of that anxiety and
those Jitters so I'm calm and present
while I'm performing and I do it before
bed the PM body scan has me out like a
light if that's all it did it would be
incredible took me years to find a
better way and now I'm passing it on to
you and you only need 5 minutes a day
the open method is simple and it works
it combines breath work meditation and
fitness they have a badass community of
people doing it all together all
committed to personal growth to help
support you my only regret is not
starting it sooner the app changed my
life it will change yours if you want to
get on my daily routine you can get 30
days free of open by visiting with
open.com weird again that that is 30
days free by visiting with
open.com weird support your body support
your mind support your life support the
show all right everybody enjoy Steve O
get into it could you use your real
voice not this
not this Persona can the real Steve show
what if you just were like afternoon I
um I was trying to work with the vocal
coach at one point buddy brutal
right he no we have the same thing I
went to a uh Cedar not Cedar Cedars is
it a Cedars person um no it's um
somebody was referred to me
by who cares yeah exactly no not that I
don't care but I don't want you to
strain to try to remember oh no no yeah
don't mind I just know it's sort of
embarrassing this you massage and you
have to like stretch your tongue and
before shows and all that right right
right right it really worked did you see
the Metallica documentary The some kind
of monster yeah uh long time ago well
what made me feel better about it was
James headfield is in the stairwell the
most metal person of all time and he's
going me me me me me me me I'm like
there's no there's no cool way to do it
you just have to go it's okay so we're
recording wel there we go thank you
right on it's great to be here you I'm
I'm really happy to we've walked past
one another many times I I um not long
ago I had a set at The Comedy Store yeah
walked in you were on stage and it was
just thunderous no
thunderous like the I mean there's just
something about the comedy store man
it's it's special isn't it it it's
unbelievable and the energy in there I
just thought man I'm swimming with
sharks tonight that's part of it though
you know what I mean it's like to me
following great people I still I still
feel it too you know obviously I'm like
for sure follow I just followed Santino
there I saw you there I think on Monday
um no before the holiday no it doesn't
matter no not in the last week or so but
um but yeah absolutely I remember uh who
who else was there this uh Eliza was
there she did great yeah she murders I
just remember thinking God I've just
gotta step it up tonight isn't that
funny that like cuz one of the things I
sincerely admire about you I'm a
spiritual person and I'm always talking
about like there's nothing to be ashamed
of there's nothing we're we're innocent
like it's okay all this like
self-acceptance I I I'm I'm excited to
talk about spiritual concepts with you
that's great well one of things and this
might sound false but I sincerely mean
it is like I just took a pee right and I
was like isn't it funny that Steve can
pee in front of people and I really I
don't like it I I'd rather not pee at a
ball game you know what I mean and what
is going on there is like a latent shame
like a like a denial of my human and you
don't have that I know that sounds funny
but like you know what I I I do I just
have it in different ways tell me um
with uh with my
standup um even though I've been doing
it like
just I've been doing it belligerently
and persistently and and and
aggressively I'm just not stopped for 13
years just just you know like I've
maintained a schedule of of touring that
that's that's unhealthy you know I I do
so many shows little on brand and yeah
somehow because I came into standup from
something else I've got this this
built-in insecurity that people don't
want to accept me oh no that's real
that's real yeah and so it doesn't
matter if you come in like Ricky Jes
creates the funniest TV show of all time
does standup I I have to imagine he was
also like do you accept me cuz you came
like late which is so silly but I get it
I get it because it can be like a
clubhouse and it's like oh these are the
real these are the real pirates and
you're a guy wearing a hat that you got
at Pirates of the Caribbean being like
yeah absolutely absolutely and over the
course of the 13 years of me doing
standup which by the way you're minted
past 10 you're mint like by anyone's
standard you know what I mean cuz
stand-ups are worried that you're not
that you're a tourist right you know 13
years that's longer than yeah I mean
they like the the reality if if my you
know my if my logical thinking applies
it's it's very Democratic if people
don't want you to be doing it then there
isn't an audience and it's going to not
continue right but for me I was able to
keep making it around to The Comedy Club
Circuit year after year and and uh and
business got better and better and it's
like getting your passport stand look I
was there right yeah um and over the
course of of the time time um my my
comedy became multimedia yeah where
um in the beginning it was just me and a
microphone then it was me and a
microphone and I would edit footage in
after the fact so that my second special
could be multimedia like yeah but not
for the audience correct for the viewing
audience yeah so I didn't have it to
lean on when I was touring the show on
tour was was uh just standup in its own
right but but then I added footage and
after the fact and that worked so well
that I really wanted to bring footage
with me on tour for my third hour let
them enjoy it yeah and um god it worked
so well that that that's the the special
I've just put out I was just watching it
this morning oh man it's a crazy way to
start your day for me it's like 900 a.m.
I just dropped my daughter off and I'm
like oh but that's it there's like a we
call it I call it the Borat Factor like
watching it in a theater I I cry for
people that watch Jackass movies or
Borat without a crowd it's so fun that
be that is the show in fact the show is
obviously the show but like it's there's
a second show is watching for sure all
sorts of people react in different ways
and and uh
so early on not not that early on but uh
certainly you know a year or more before
I taped this
special I sent a a reference cut a
recording of of the show with all the
multimedia baked in to my buddy Johnny
Knoxville yeah and and he said hey man
this is great but you know he said if
you if you could make your delivery more
conversational oh wow that would that
would help that's a hard thing that's a
hard note to give too it's a hard note
to get it's but it's good to have a
friend that could be like couldn't agree
more I'm trying to help yeah but most
people would just go it's great
yeah oh no nox's always been very
thoughtful very candid that's that's
like me and biglia biglia Mike big will
be like I don't like this joke and
you're like what oh god like I'm so
what's the Hollywood cliche your
managers are all like it's the best it's
the best yes people cuz they're I mean
that's self-preservation they want you
to release it they want it to make money
and all they don't really care or as
much as a friend a real friend for sure
and and he he always been that way in
Knoxville and so I continued touring
with the show and I was I I
was trying so hard to to just be more
natural and loose and conversational and
I just couldn't feel it working and
ultimately what I did was uh I hired a
speaking coach not a vocal coach but a
speaking coach obviously to uh yeah cuz
you still have the rasp right that was
the joke you you wanted someone to help
you speak more naturally not uh not
sound right yeah so with the speaking
coach got the the you know recording of
the of the show and and and watched it
and and the the speaking coach said to
me why uh do you have no problem in the
vignette the multimedia component yeah
you get very loose very natural you know
yeah yet on stage you have this kind of
uh you know fear is at play stiffness or
and and and what we arrived at is that
and when I'm when I'm in the doing my
thing on in the vignette it's like I'm
you know like it's so natural for me
well you're also in control your fiance
is shooting you you decide like let's
roll now right I have to imagine you're
like I feel like it let's do it we can
edit it it's different on they see
everything on stage yeah is that am I
right I I think what it is is that
um is is that that just insecurity the
when I'm on stage it's like oh you know
like like I I feel there's some
self-consciousness like oh now I'm
performing standup and and people don't
want to accept me as that and and I
think that we we we really chipped away
at it really broke and and I just
developed this Mantra of going out on
stage like dude I'm just the guy in the
clips you know I'm not out here trying
to yeah trying to impersonate what I
think a standup comedian is right no I'm
I'm going out there like if it's a TED
Talk and and I'm I'm speaking as the
world's
foremost uh expert in in uh poo poo
jokes and stuff yeah yeah yeah no I get
it yeah poo poo jokes yeah scatological
humor I'm the best in the world like I'm
I'm I'm you're also a pioneer of this
other thing but that can carry over into
this you don't have to reinvent the
wheel but that's what's interesting to
me
watching obviously listening to your
podcast and seeing you evolve I feel
like you know you've thought about this
but you kind of just alluded to it when
I see you doing standup I see somebody
who had to get
over the
idea that you're not valuable if you're
not back flipping into a v of AET right
like why would you watch me and isn't
that
was that young steo hangup it's like
I'll do anything and you started at 10:
and now you're telling us an anecdote
about an Uber that you took once it's
like you probably have to like
Greenlight that your feelings and your
private thoughts are as valuable as an
extreme stunt yeah I mean I'm like I
like it gave me anxiety you describing
like I'm fre me out I can't talk about
Uber no not
okay funny that like you will see me is
that the voice of young steo you will
see me or is it more I will shock you is
it about them or is it about you I I I
think that I'm just left the bar you
know where the bar lives is is a a
terrifying height and uh to come in
underneath the B it's that's something
that has less to do with an audience or
an audience's expectations than I think
a standard that I hold myself to yeah so
I mean I don't know where that stand
where did that standard come from
starting at the beginning and working up
to the standup and not to be too therapy
but I'm I'm genuinely interested sure
like I got I'll start with this I got
into standup because I really felt like
my parents were lost in their own worlds
you know what I mean like the dinner
table I was
like and I so when I was away from my
family and found a way for people to
like see me and and and laughter is this
great proof that you've been heard not
only were you heard you were understood
wow I like that and they got your
perspective so when I like complain
about my parents and I'm like and then
he says and they laugh I'm like thank
you right that was crazy or whatever so
that was the need if you were start you
started by submitting your tapes to the
guy who would go on to direct jackass
right do you
remember I mean there's so many ways to
come at it where you like the world is
absurd why are we all acting like it's
normal uh we're all in danger why are we
acting like we're safe like what what
was the voice I have a theory on this
and it's
that
mortality is is such a uh a problem yeah
for all of us that the way that I view
it our human experience is a cruel prank
on us because we have only one instinct
which is to survive yeah and one
guarantee we won't that's the cosmic
joke so we're ice sculptures we're ice
we're melting ice sculptures and some of
the ice sculptures are like I have a
billion dollars and it's like who cares
dip [__] or some of them are like in the
70s I had a hit record who cares dip
[__] like I'm reading the denial of
death right now and it's all about the
UN like everything we do is driven by
this like unspoken so repressed
unconscious war is some dictator being
like the more bodies that fall the the
more I am and the more I'm served and
look how real I am and then history
laughs it's like Napoleon what are you
you're gone you're gone just like the
postman for sure is gone like so it's
this equalizer so you're saying there
was a sort of like look at this well
well yeah and when I
was uh you
know failing out of the University of
Miami in
1993 um I I I was very acutely aware of
my inability to make it to class to to
get passing grades there was no chance
that I was going to graduate from
University I could not do it and every
single attempt that I had ever made to
hold a job was equally catastrophic
right so you're not like fitting in it's
a lonely feeling could I could not keep
a job like no matter like I I could not
bring myself to do anything that I was
not passionate about doing and it wasn't
a choice you weren't being punk rock you
literally W built that literally I
couldn't and so in my view I like
woefully lacked the basic survival
skills needed to navigate the world we
live in right and I expected
that it was my fate that I was going to
fail miserably at life and die young and
having failed pathetically right and and
so there was like an extra like uh just
frustration
despair like I just I I'm just not cut
out a and um I think that it's not a
mystery why my first stunts were were
were just so by
Design uh
to mock lash out at like there was very
angsty yeah like I was hanging off like
a 12 story balcony by my bare hands yeah
and and and uh you know I Let Go
dropping onto the 11th floor below like
ah and I did it like very drunk you know
like it was like I could die you know it
was like and it was like me lashing out
at death yeah um and and there was
something about the fact of videotaping
it
which
absolutely cheats death I was like I'm
going to be dead yeah I'll like it like
having failed and dead gone but these
videos that I'm making even if I die
they will me and so my early
stunts in some ways I really feel that I
it was me scrambling around frantically
trying to pack my message into a bottle
so that I could be discovered it postly
yeah as of the V go [__] of the video
camera it reminds me there there's a lot
of
um I don't know I don't want can you say
Primal like uh tribes in South America
which I know you lived in South America
but like I'm thinking about like the
yanami and all these different Indians
and whatever I don't know why we call
them Indians anyway I'm really having a
hard time talking about this without
being offensive I'm just saying it goes
really far back that like a shaman would
gouge his back with hooks and hang there
in the in the village so there's the
baskets here's the food for tonight oh
there's the shaman he's bleeding out
they would call it death tripping they
would they would literally take
themselves as close as they could to
death to then have a psychedelic
experience like a vision and come back
or standing on poles like with one foot
there's all this sort of stuff so it's
not it's actually it is new you are a
Pioneer but it's also seems to be part
of absolutely I I don't think I don't
think different place yeah I don't think
there's a lot of new stuff Avail isn't
that weird but you I mean you were in
the MTV days being like what is this and
it's like well there's actually a
historical precedent for this is you're
right the one
thing the one special thing we all have
is our relationship to our own mortality
and you wanted to turn that into a
identity right and you did um I think
that that people are very very uh averse
to even contemplating their mortality
and I think that that is a a grave
mistake you see a corpse they put makeup
on it they cut your belly off like if
you had a huge belly you're flat you
look great it's it's [__] perverse
and I say this all the time but like Ram
D used to talk about how in India when
someone died they would carry them on a
board through the street just a dead
body not adorned not fixed up just
here's death right and that would help
everyone kind of understand and remember
it and here we hide birth the birth
process is like it's a little bit like
factory farming which I know is
something else you feel about it's like
it's over here let's not look at that
and our deaths are it's over here and we
won't let you see it until it's pretty
and then it's it's just like kindest
little bite I I don't think that we
would want to see it if it's pretty like
I I agree I think that
um that even
being old is is not it's not acceptable
it's like to be to be elderly yeah is an
offense because we don't have Elders we
just have old useless people I'm not
saying that's true right right which is
like well they can't produce they can't
consume it's not it's not even that it's
that elderly people serve as a reminder
of our mortality and we don't care to be
reminded of our mortality it so we are
offended by old people and want them out
of our line of sight and it's weakness
too it's it's mortality and it's and
it's cousin weakness it's like I'm
watching my parents get older and I'm
also watching people in their Circle not
be able to spend time with them because
it's hard when somebody is shaking as
they're drinking their tea and has to
ride a little chair up the stairs but
like I'm grateful ra again ROM twice in
10 minutes but he's like in our culture
it's like we go out and the leaves are
changing to Red they're dying and we go
out with green paint and we paint them
and we go they're still green they're
still green this is what Botox is I feel
horrible for the burden on everybody but
women in particular that you're like you
can't AG remember the new Top Gun they
didn't have the same woman yeah I didn't
oh it doesn't matter and then I looked
up a picture of that woman and she like
aged appropriately yeah and I'm not
dragging Tom Cruz but I'm like it's sort
of [__] weird that the hero of our
country is 60 something and looks 30
something and we're all just sort of
like yeah yeah death won't come like
what are we going to do when Tom Cruz
dies what are we going to do as a nation
it's so funny my my
uh a friend of mine said
man if it wasn't for Scientology Tom
Cruz would be the coolest guy who ever
lived you know
can you imagine if he wasn't just can
you imagine I wasn't and very very
solemn just staring out the window God
like he was so close he was so close
well he does what does he do death
defying stunts as well yeah and he makes
a point to be like that's really me so
not only am I old and I'm defying that
but I'm also tempting death how many
times did he jump off that mountain on
the bike it's the same service and don't
I have this joke it doesn't really work
but I go you ever catch yourself
watching TV and you're like I can't die
I'm Captain America like you you project
yourself onto these Heroes and or Tom
Cruz you go as with Tom so with me as
you're eating a hogy you know what I
mean like it doesn't matter cuz you can
imagine that's the service they provide
is you will also look great you will
also cheat death
forever yeah it's crazy and and and the
thing you know like to take it to the to
the spiritual that this whole like idea
of
death and and I mean it's an illusion
right I mean do we not have enough
evidence now that
uh like with all the the people's
accounts of of near-death experiences
where they they experience their their
uh their life review yeah yeah yeah and
and I mean are we not like at a place
where where we can actually understand
that that we're not the body and there's
nothing to be afraid of yeah but that's
again that goes back to you and I know I
I don't want to be too absurd by saying
sometimes it's just a good old kick in
the nuts sometimes a cigar is just a
cigar and it's just funny and it's great
but this is the podcast where we go a
little bit deeper and go there are these
Aesthetics in India that throw their
[__] at people and they eat Gories yeah
yeah and they're trying I think I I
don't have a full understanding but
they're trying to say like don't you see
this isn't real don't you see this isn't
like your idea of being a good boy and
God will love me is so absurd and I know
God's love is so encompassing that I'm
going to do everything weird to freak
you out because that's how sure I am
that we're okay yeah we filmed with
theories really yeah a couple times and
uh more than once well went that once
was for um my my show wild boys which
was sort of a you know a homoerotic
comedy nature show and and it was just
me and one other guy Chris ponus and and
we had a really pretty fantastic
experience with the the agoris they they
were just wild then we went to India
again uh to film the second Jackass
movie and we filmed with the aorus with
the whole cast and we found that the
whole cast
of Jackass um was not um as tolerant as
just me and ponus were they just wasn't
had like they were aor phobic they were
doing they were doing their their agory
thing and and it didn't fly with all the
guys what were they
doing um just kind of acting a fool like
like they they I don't remember anything
in particular but I think there was like
some leg humping kind of a thing and
it's like don't hump my leg dude you
like the the the tolerance for for for
uh jackass wasn't wasn't there yeah they
had met their match would you say yeah
but but I just my experience wasn't that
they were quite as thoughtful as you're
suggesting I hear what you're saying I I
even as I was saying that I was like I
don't know if it's that intellectual
yeah they were they were
quite I I don't know they they were not
they were wild yeah they they were they
were just trying to get a rise was was
our our deal my impression yeah drinking
whiskey out of human skulls and yeah and
uh think
yeah interesting yeah interesting guys I
think it does tie to what we're talking
about but who knows on some level yeah
but I think that they've kind of uh
that're they're just not uh coming from
a place of of uh God is accepting you
know they're more they're more just like
look at me you know
like yeah
and which I can relate to so much um
it's it's interesting too that um
that death is not such a taboo subject
and and Elders are appreciated in the
the Eastern Hemisphere yeah yeah yeah
and they think we're nuts and and did
you know for example postpartum in
countries where the mother and the
grandmother like sometimes both
grandmothers all live in the same house
postpartum numbers are like really low
because it's just like we're supposed to
be together generations of women your
mother is supposed to be with the new
mother and the grandmother and and and
grandfather like the whole thing is
supposed to be supporting and the fact
that we isolate in these rectangles yeah
we all go off to our rectangles is
deeply unnatural and we know this uh but
we don't really do anything about it
right it's crazy man yeah it's it's
super crazy what when you talk about the
agor r rubbing the jackass guys the
wrong way I have to imagine one of my
questions I just wrote what's it like
being you and to make that a little bit
more
specific you know you're coming to do
this podcast and I get a little nervous
not really because I I've listened to
your podcast and I know you're a
thoughtful guy but more than me being
worried that you're going to like think
I'm a prank guy and somehow sabotage me
is your day-to-day life like a fan is
going to just see you and be like he's
the guy that likes being with a board
like is
that I don't think that's so much
it um I think that that
for fans or or just people who are aware
of me and encounter me in a public
setting that I'm considerably more
approachable than a lot of uh people
with with u you know profiles Tom Hanks
you might ignore Tom Hanks cuz oh my God
it's you might be like oh you know like
people just they I feel that uh I'm kind
of a people's guy like it's it's very
permissible to um to to approach me and
and be you know nobody like licks you um
it that's that's kind of rare that's a
little bit more rare it reminds me of
punk rock where spitting on the guy
singing is actually kind of like oh
that's their hello like I I remember I
saw rans said when I was 17 and someone
hawked not just spit but like a lugie on
Tim Armstrong's face and it just dripped
down his face he didn't even wipe it and
I was like oh this is a weird culture so
people don't tase you no I mean there
have been situations like that but it's
certainly not the norm yeah I'm glad to
hear that yeah yeah it's not the norm I
I you know what like I it's all I ever
wanted was was attention so it's it's
fitting that that I I you know that that
I should get it and be okay with it
um yeah it's it's it's cool right but as
you're getting older and you're having
your attention me needs met in other
ways your podcast meets you stand up
your fiance so now you're growing up and
you don't I got to like when I saw Eric
Andre and and uh Knoxville tasing each
other on that show they were doing yeah
like this is me but I was like how old
is Johnny I'm just sort of like can we
give this guy a break but it's almost
like I worry about the obligation like
well I have to do this I did that do you
ever feel that way do you ever just want
to
um I think I do feel
obligated on some level I feel like uh
you
know my next move has to be crazier and
and you take this out it it won't come
out for some time but I had a a
conversation with Caitlyn Jenner and and
Caitlyn Jenner was uh she was saying
that I made her think of Elton John and
how he wore these huge elaborate
costumes and each costume had to be even
crazier and just got to a point where
he's just
like yeah you know like at which point
do you see the bar and just think and
just I'm not gonna you know I did it I'm
just going to wear a tuxedo yeah just G
just just wear a suit a normal thing um
and and that that had such a profound
impact on me to the the the Elton John
metap for I it was just like man I got
one more I got one more elaborate outfit
in
me and then and and then I'd like to
think that uh that I can
you know I've been evolving with
podcasting with standup and you know all
of these soety different things for sure
um that that I think that I can find a
way forward that doesn't
involve like high impact yeah stunts
kind of thing I thought about you I I
just picked up my I have a 5-year-old
daughter and I picked her up yesterday
actually was a friend of hers I flipped
them upside down and I love I'm a big
guy so I love doing that sort of stuff
and I just felt something in my low back
it wasn't like a pull or anything but I
was like like I needed to get a massage
like it was like a therapeutic or I
won't be able to walk and I was like
that's got to be at at play I mean you
probably for all the great scar stories
you have you probably also have like in
my stand up special I told a story about
hurting myself cuz I crouched in the
shower and and put my face back and
forth I threw my back out just just
doing that so I mean you have to have
like some pretty lame you know injury
stories as well sure yeah I mean I think
that all of my uh issues are just
standard 49y old dude stuff yeah you
know I don't think uh like I I'm I have
a torn meniscus I'm getting operated on
in two days and nothing happened right
it was just your body yeah I think I was
actually riding a bicycle like um the
story is nothing yeah not nothing time
right so it must be cool though because
I'd love to talk to you about pain and
courage and we're talking about
overcoming stage fright and stuff I know
we were getting into standup but like if
you were if I were I'll have to get a
colonoscopy soon and then I I'm like if
I could somehow bottle what you have is
there any way that you could
describe how you do things you don't
want to do and how you say yes to fear
and pain because it actually is useful
like we have to do
some people biglia has to get a camera
up his urethra you know to scan for
whatever a couple times a year so if we
could like if there was a pill the steo
pill but what is the what is the process
you're about to do a thing and it's
going to hurt what do you do do you not
think about it
um a very useful tool for me um is one
two three go i' I've never backed out
like one two three
go yeah you just make a deal with
yourself we go on go yeah I think this
whole civilization the Lynch pins of the
whole thing are people like you going
like Oppenheimer it's just like it could
EV vaporized the whole known universe 1
2 3 go and they do it yeah um my my my
uh my bull rider buddy once said
profoundly
you're never ready it just becomes your
turn wow um being okay with not
Readiness yeah I I like that a lot um I
I think that in in a general sense that
you know I don't have any
particular threshold for for pain like I
don't have a tolerance or I just and
because if I did there wouldn't be uh um
there wouldn't be that uh
trepidation that there wouldn't be that
reaction you know that makes everything
compelling um yeah so you need a real
guy doing it you don't want who what
there was a superhero that couldn't feel
pain you don't want that yeah I would be
indifferent it would be very boring so
you need a real guy yeah you need a real
guy and I think that if I have a some
kind of a a superpower
it's quite simply that my my desire for
attention outweighs my desire for
Comfort yeah it's really okay so to
bring that to Earth cuz not a lot of
people listening are stunt people but
isn't it funny that like bodybuilders
are doing a very similar thing the the
silly the way that I can relate is I I
like cold exposure and every time I do
it my body says don't do it right and
then I just do it that's my one two
three go yeah I like I learned that for
my knee that ice baths very helpful yeah
and so just a couple days ago I did like
my first one yeah and God I hate it of
course it's the worst yeah you you
always you do that here I I don't live
here anymore but where we live we we
used to have it right there and it made
the move and I use it every day and what
temperature is the water that you get
into 39 39 okay it's which is as cold as
it goes but I think you could it freezes
at like 34 or something so you could go
a little bit lower yeah but that
I don't know the the phenomenon of like
tricking like there's a there's a part
of you that's this is kind of spiritual
I suppose that's watching your body
that's watching your mind and your mind
and your body are saying no and I think
there's something whether it's
weightlifting so super athletes stunt
people even something as simple as
getting in a a tub of cold water it's
weird that there's a separate part of us
that can go override like going to all
the lights are flashing don't do it
right I isn't there some sort of clue
that there's another part of us that can
go CU you know we do that with our moods
like you can choose a better mood like
you can choose a better Outlook you can
there's an overriding Factor that's very
useful and a stunt or cold exposure or
weightlifting is just like another
expression of that same mechanism
perhaps how long do you stay in the 39°
between 3 and 7 Minutes wow W you know
why you know why you don't want to stay
in longer why cuz it'll take too long to
heat up it's you you'll have to like sit
in a hot tub for 30 minutes to get back
and that's the risk so no nobody TR like
nobody says this more than you but don't
try that and it takes a lot of training
you know the first time I did it I was
blue blue lipped it was it was at 60 I
was blue lipped and shaking and then the
next time you just you build that you do
build up over time and then it gets so
it's actually easy and that's why you
start staying in for 7 minutes because I
am chasing an endorphin I'm an addict as
well so it's like I'm chasing like a
natural there's no better feeling than 7
Minutes in cold water and then getting
in a hot tub it's it's I call it the
full body jizz it's it's incredible you
just don't know what to do you're like
it's it is like an
orgasm yeah so so so tell me about uh
being an addict like uh you're a guy in
recovery I I didn't go through the
program uh although I admire the program
and enjoy I have a lot of friends in the
program and everything I hear about it I
love um but I just noticed that like can
I here's my theory I'm going to put it
to you okay alcohol more than drugs I
still occasionally do psychedelics as a
as a I know that sounds like a weird
thing but it's as a spiritual thing I do
occasionally do psychedelics uh and weed
but
booze and I'd love to hear what you
think about this I noticed that booze
was the only thing that gave gave me as
much attention as I wanted the world to
give me meaning it was a guaranteed
experience you drink this liquid
something will happen it won't ignore
you does that make
sense um the alcohol won't ignore you it
will it will attend to you okay it could
be good it could be bad but it won't
ignore you and somebody who
wants wants something I
there's a want and alcohol would give it
so like I felt that
way you know someone who wants attension
and someone who wants alcohol pretty
similar to me like I was like change how
I feel and it would go okay yeah and it
was reliable and and I I recognized I
was like this is never going to stop
like talk about the witnessing thing
that was like I know the body seems to
like this even the parts that it doesn't
like need to step in and and
stop yeah it's interesting um when it
comes to
attention I remember being the kid in in
school who when I had to get up in front
of the class and give a class
presentation I would like the the
pressure and you could hear my voice
like trembling like with nervousness and
you know like um it it's it's really
interesting to me that whole dynamic
because I I I wanted so much the the
attention the the the approval the
praise but I was so afraid yeah of not
being liked yeah you have to risk your
worst fear to get your greatest treasure
right so it's just this uh it's just
kind of a rock and a hard spot situation
like I want to be in this but I'm
terrified of it and um there was a uh a
report
card that my sister saves all the you
know she's like the family historian and
um she we were going through stuff when
I was uh setting about writing my first
book and I found this sixth grade report
card where the teacher wrote uh about me
that that I I I don't know if the word
desperate was used but I but I so crave
Steve so craves the uh the
the approval and praise of his peers but
everything he
does seeking it brings about the
opposite results oh wow and it was so
piercing to me because like you know
there are just tragic situations
where you want something so bad and your
way of trying to get it like brings
about the opposite results yeah and you
have to risk that and you actually kind
of have to endure it it reminds me of
standup it's like you want to be a
standup be terrible at standup for 8
years you know what I mean like pretty
bad right pretty bad at least for three
years you'll
stink for sure and um that you know it
calls to mind too like that I think when
when people have a stutter that the
stutter
presents specifically at the times that
they don't they don't want it to you
know like and that there's something
really really like uh tragic in that
yeah I wonder what that is I mean like
don't when it's most important that you
don't do something is when you're going
to do it the most you ever realize I
mean I'm sure you do sometimes I I think
I was stoned and I realized that I was
the greatest threat to myself and I
don't mean that in a suicidal way I mean
I'm the
one like I was planning on smoking 5 Meo
DMT and I was like then I got stoned a
couple weeks prior and I was
like like my body was talking to me
being like you're the problem like
you're signing us up for Paradigm
shifting psychedelics so the stutter
potentially Lord knows I don't know it's
like the protector is going like let's
just shut everything down and then we
can just sit still and be ignored but at
least we won't be in danger as opposed
to overcoming it and getting people
looking at you and then you're risking
it thinks you're risking even more right
and you know what I got into this with
that speaking coach it was very very
much more like therapy then you know and
and that my my protector like my my
protector like a it I've got some
mechanism trying to protect me yes but
it it's not doing a good job but I mean
also didn't it I mean all these things
you did took a kid who couldn't pass
School couldn't keep a job yeah and then
it was like I'm always trying just
recognize that everyone's doing the same
thing what I'm doing is like culturally
acceptable I I'm a a comedian I got good
at comedy and I do comedy and then you
watch someone who's not shiny and what
are they doing and it's like they're
doing the exact same thing they're
finding what is unique about them and
highlighting it and and dimming the
lights on what is deplorable about them
so in a sense like what you
did really
worked yeah like the protector was right
it's like let's go cling to a balcony
and now you you know probably live in a
nice house yeah yeah I mean I I I can't
argue with that I I I really can't and
um I wonder what the the parallel is
there with with uh you know the
alcohol yeah I I could see that my my I
thought I was going to blow you away
with my attent alcohol gives you
attention but that is that is my thing
mushrooms is a good example like if you
take mushrooms you have like 4 hours of
this thing only for you even if it's bad
you can't say it's ignoring you do you
know what I mean like it's like this
thing is very interested in me right now
my experience with mushrooms was that it
made me um
introspective to a point of discomfort
and an
introspective where I I I just found
myself
uh
just tearing myself apart with criticism
just arriving at the conclusion that I
just suck really yeah like I'm very mean
to my I was like I'm not going to say I
I when I did take mushrooms I found
myself very mean to myself and arriving
at very negative conclusions about
myself wow that's kind of what about
have you ever taken MDMA
uh it like I remember that being just
ecstasy right yeah yeah ecstasy MMA with
a little bit of an upper I think yeah I
took plenty of that and largely had all
good experiences but did you ever have a
therapeutic kind of feeling where it was
the opp here I'm just leading you to
what I I took MDMA and I was like I had
the very visceral
experience of sweeping my own Street
like there were all these doubts and
like I'm stupid I'm not I'm not and all
that got swept away and I could see that
my street was paved with gold and I was
like it was very like look at you even
the podcast it was like you share your
insecurities and people get to listen in
and feel less alone and your comedy and
I was like overwhelmed that it got swept
away did you ever receive anything like
that no man that that sounds wonderful
but that sounds wonderful but no what
about in therapy have you gotten to a or
just in your conscious regular State
have you gotten to a place where you're
like you know what I've gotten to and
and uh I haven't needed any kind of uh
drugs or or anything to get to this but
like I I've discovered recently and I'm
sure it's not a new discovery but but
I've I've you know been reminded
recently that I can take the best
circumstance like I have a really good
life you know I've got a really really
good life very fortunate circumstances
and I can
take any
situation
and make myself miserable really like
despite the best
circumstances I can just be very mean to
myself I can feel I can catastrophize
yeah like even like my my situation is
great but oh but but it's not going to
be okay like I'm just barreling towards
like uh some awful situation like I can
uh really really like my wife's going to
leave me that sort of stuff yeah I'm
just going to I'm going to lose
everything like uh you know it's all
over I'll be discovered I'm done yeah
that's funny because your work is so
like you can't discover me I'll show it
to you yeah I don't know that that I'll
be discovered as it as much but but
people are just done with me I think uh
you know whatever whenever if they were
interested they've lost their interest
but do you still need that like you used
to um it's okay to be honest I mean if
we do we do um oh I don't think that
there's really much dishonesty in
me I just meant don't I felt like it was
potentially an embarrassing question
like I'm saying like but you've clearly
grown and you don't need it maybe we do
no I definitely I I I think that that
this this uh attention seeking thing is
is very much in my DNA there's no
divorcing myself from that but I think
that the best I can strive to do is to
find separation between the Persona yeah
you know the the the career
and you know and and just whoever I am
yeah and it's very very important to do
that because as long as my
identity my self-worth my self-esteem is
tied
to the the value of steveo as a
commodity in the entertainment world
yeah then then I'm like that I can't you
know I'm [__] like it's just not that
that's that's just a road to misery and
so it was so important to me to um you
know to to learn how to have a healthy
relationship and find a life partner
some you know and really like
cultivate uh an identity and and
existence separate from all that so that
it can be okay for me to get old and and
be a walking party
fell you know
yeah this episode friends is brought to
us sponsored by better help my family is
not great at gift giving I'm talking
about my mom and my dad growing up we
would always give my dad a tie or
something and he would open it up and
sarcastically say just exactly what I
wanted which was not what we wanted we
wanted a better reaction than that
whether or not your family gives gifts
or does it well during the holidays you
get to Define how you give gifts to
yourself and the holidays are a great
time to do that so whether it's by
starting therapy going easier on
yourself during the tough moments or
treating yourself to a day of complete
rest remember to give yourself some love
this holiday season I have benefited so
much from talk therapy I always say it
is greater than the sum of its parts
talking to a trained professional has
helped me through breakups job
transition family stuff it has made my
life so much better it's not just
talking it's actual active healing I'm a
huge believer in it and better help has
made it so easy to bring it into your
life so if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
entirely online designed to be
convenient venient flexible and suited
to your schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get match with a
licensed therapist you can even switch
therapist at any time for no additional
charge and whatever you're going through
I swear talking about it with a
professional helps it's changed my life
it can absolutely change yours for the
better so in the SE season of giving
give yourself what you need with better
help visit betterhelp.com weirdo toay to
get 10% off your first month that's
better help h
el.com weirdo we're also brought To Us
by our friends at next Evo my favorite
CBD company and their stress gummies
Carry Me Through not just visiting
family or anything distinctly stressful
but just holiday parties which can be
overwhelming for me and the blend of CBD
and ashwaganda helps me ease into
stressful situations in my life and are
an absolute holiday Lifesaver people
have tried CBD in the past that don't
know what it's all about didn't get it
next Evo has crack the code and they get
it into your system quickly and reliably
so you can dial in the dose feel the
effects and start benefiting today some
things don't mix brushing your teeth
after you drank orange juice oil and
water is another classic our bodies guys
don't absorb CD CBD oil very well so
when you reach for oilbased CBD products
you could be absorbing as little as 6%
of what's on the label next Evo Naturals
has developed a proprietary water
soluble form of CBD clinically tested
multiple times which is proven to work
faster and absorb four times faster so
you can stay calmer or sleep better
during this stressful time of year CBD
obviously only works when it gets into
your body if it gets into your body and
only next Evo has proven that their all
natural gummies and capsules absorb four
times better than most oil-based
products it's not well known but CBD
isn't actually an oil other compan iies
dissolve it in oil because it's cheap
and it's an easy way to make products
like tinctures and gummies but CBD only
works when it gets into you so their
products absorb faster at next Evo
better and are more delicious with
absolutely no hempy after aftertaste I
can absolutely attest to that with so
many choices this is the one with the
brand data next Evo Naturals are proven
to absorb four times better and their
extra strength daily Wellness CBD
gummies are two times stronger than
regular strength which are incredible
again their stress gummies are a life
changer so don't waste your time on
oilbased CBD that might not work upgrade
to better natural solutions from next
Evo go to next evo.com and use code
weird for 25% off any order or up to 60%
off as a new subscriber wow that's 25%
off or 60% off as a new subscriber at
neext evo.com and use code weird all
right everybody let's get back to sto
I I love that it that also reminds me I
ideally we all have a safe way to let
out our shadow and it seems like I say
this all the time but it had a profound
impact on me again a tribal thing mask
work that put on the mask and like the
devil that put on the devil mask and
then oh I got the devil mask you'd look
at your reflection and then you would
act devilish and and that was sort of
like an agreed upon thing we have this
with Halloween but this was like a
ceremonial like oh he's being the wicked
devil and of course he just took a dump
on the fire or whatever it might have
been right so in a good World you'd have
base Steve and then you'd be able to try
on and put on steo when you need him
yeah I think
uh and I think that I've actually on
some level developed the ability to do
that yeah and I think that uh that
there's um
a blending I think I live a double life
where when I need to be super crazy and
do some super wild stuff I I have the
ability to turn that on yeah and uh and
and I'm very calculated about it too
yeah you know um I'm very deliberate
about when I amp up the crazy how do you
know it's
time um like do you get itchy do you
start being weird is your wife like you
need to jump out a helicopter no no no
nothing like that it's not to solve a
behavior or a feeling no no no no no
nothing like that um it's it's very very
you know it's like asking you
when when's it time to to write a joke
right like it's interesting because I
will start dreaming about it like I'll
dream okay I'll have a recurring dream
that I'm looking at my set list and I
don't know what it means I get anxious I
get a little bit irritable and then I'm
like my wife will say you need to go do
stand up right like it's this like
medicine
that I do out and I'm always trying to
do it as little as possible okay like
meaning I I just want to water it enough
to keep it healthy and alive I don't
want to overwater it and become a
perversion or something okay so but do
you have just to be Frank could you
retire could I retire no I don't mean
like psychologically like are you sad
enough that you could
retire um and then we can talk about
whether or not you could retire I think
uh I I think that that that's the the
toughest
question
because
the the the more money you save the more
financially insecure you feel I think is
a weird dynamic what do you mean I mean
that they've done surveys of of people
and uh found that the more money they
have the more that they experience
Financial insecurity like particularly
people with over $10 million of savings
feel they report that they
feel uh financially insecure and and I
think that that's evidence of a reality
where um we don't get satisfaction from
uh saving large amounts of money that
actually in fact the money creates a
vacuum where the more you have the more
you need and and comes this crazy and
and so when you ask me am I set enough
to
retire
um I suppose I suppose I would have to
really change my my lifestyle and and
reduce my my overhead helicop budget my
fixed my fixed costs are are pretty
absurd and and uh scary but don't you
think you might as you were saying that
I was like Elton John came up again he
got OD Ed at some point and it was like
embarrassing and there was a trial and I
remember one of the things they brought
to the jury and the judge was you spend
like something like $26,000 a month on
flowers and I don't know why I know that
like what is this public shaming but I
was like when you have infinite money
you start spending more money because I
think there's part of you that
knows that's at least in part the engine
that keeps the thing that actually makes
you fulfilled which is your work and if
you have if if you're always spending
you'll need to make more but you'll get
this byproduct of fulfillment from the
work that you do to make that money yeah
I mean I don't know I I just know that
um that I find myself uh a little bit
frustrated that
um the like the human nature applies to
me you know like uh like like say for
example um you know the the the more
successful I became the more money I
earned uh it was very natural for me to
uh like oh you're going to get this
percentage you're going like uh just to
be I I I it was very natural for me to
recognize the people who helped me
achieve my success and and have them
participate in it and and so that like
I've you know and and by doing that I've
cultivated the you know a loyalty
amongst my team that that's really
really uh unbelievable and and I I only
recently have I uh you
know adopted and developed a more
sophisticated level of accounting to
really be able to see like how it's all
shaking out and really really
understanding wow I made that much money
and held on to that little of it you
know and uh uh and in that uh kind of
Revelation you know comes a fear and and
then like ah I gotta I've got to like
really uh curtail my generosity on some
level you know like it's I don't want to
be the guy who made earned millions and
millions of dollars and like MC Hammer
doesn't have it all yeah so well you're
generosity slight sidebar into economics
is coming out of your gross you're
you're giving gifts based on I give you
a million dollar and then you're giving
$100,000 but then you actually your tax
to 500 then your reps take 30% and now
you're making 300,000 and you gave
100,000 away and and and and you just
gave a third away yeah it's it's all uh
just just kind
of I I'm I'm I'm at the
intersection of uh
my you know I I want to be like generous
I want to not you know I want to just
not not care be creative and and and
it's all good and but I also want to be
smart so like you know the the ego is is
here to to help us survive because we we
are biological organisms that need to
eat and need you know but on a spiritual
level like we're you know our our
actual well-being comes from from Love
andh and so the the balance of of
survival and and and logic heart yeah
head and heart and so I'm at this uh and
it's just I feel like I'm I'm in a
crunch point where uh I'm I'm like
having
to acknowledge that human nature applies
to me and it's a bummer yeah it's a
bummer no I know know I totally hear
that it reminds me it's so relatable
what you're saying to everybody not just
Showbiz people negotiating millions of
dollars but we're going like I think the
reason the Trope exists this was just in
Red Dead Redemption to did you play that
by any chance doesn't matter you're out
there stapling your nuts you can't be
playing it's hard to get a thrill from a
video game but you know cops and movies
are always a day away from retirement
and then they get shot yeah you know and
I think the reason we see that
as like profoundly true is we all the
cops going like one more job one more
job one more job when really so one of
the things that is really strange to me
is the level of Consciousness or the
mindset that Fosters success Fosters a
lot of money is exactly the mindset that
makes it impossible to enjoy it yeah cuz
you're always you're hungry you're
driven you're itchy and you you had to
use all that hunger and drive and
itchiness to get to this point and now
you can't sit on the beach I'm not
saying that's what I'm hearing you say
I'm saying that's something we all have
to work with is like you can relax a
little bit you can relax that that mean
that's very interesting that's very
interesting and
um I I last year I published my second
book yeah and um the the final chapter
of my second book begins with the
question are you happy M italicized you
know are you happy and I go on to
describe that that question is
uh always bothered me that uh that I've
found it
invasive uh offensive because my initial
Instinct has always been am I happy like
I feel like I do some kind of
a like a you know mental scan of my body
like am I happy and I everything tells
me no I'm not you know I'm not happy I'm
I'm actually gripped by anxiety I'm like
just a a ball of stress that that my
core belief that my default setting is
is one of believing that that even if
everything's okay now it's not going to
be okay right you know like I'm not
going to be okay well the ego this is
around us as well the ego which is what
you're scanning yeah and that's not a
bad thing that's what we do when people
say are you happy we look around the
contents of our mind our psyche our
bodies and the truth is this is straight
rdas he goes the ego can only experience
peace for like the briefest of moment I
hand you the Oscar you get it for a
moment but the question that's super
important I think is is the scanning
mechanism that's looking for the quality
called Happiness is that neutral
awareness is it happy and I think when
we invest vestigate not just take it as
my word but when we investigate the
nature of the flashlight not what the
flashlight Shines
on oh is there happiness in here but is
the
flashlight made of happiness is it made
of peace and that's the answer but it's
as tricky as a knife stabbing itself how
do you turn a flashlight to look at its
own quality and that's what the
spiritual practice is is going all of
those feelings happiness success anxiety
are you anxious right now I'm assuming
you're not so these
things but what I'm saying is you're not
angry right now and other times you're
angry so these are clouds going through
the sky and we want to identify with the
sky but the ego can't come that's the
[__] the ego is stuck in the human
predicament but I do think there's a
part of us that isn't and that and
identifying with that is the only piece
it's the only one I just had good news f
good for about 30 minutes I timed it I
timed it I was like when will this Good
Feeling lasted 30 minutes and it was a
big one so that's [__] right well
what I arrived at you know because
uh we live in a society where it's not
um it's not okay to say I'm not happy no
so say are you happy like you you can't
say as a matter of fact no I'm not I'm
not happy like it's just not you're a
failure yeah it's not an acceptable
answer think that's why I I the the
question always bothered me so much you
know it's like like I don't [__] know
if I'm Happ like it's new business like
you know like um but I really chewed on
it more and more I thought about it and
you know why why should it bother me so
much and what I arrived
at is
uh I I actually became okay with it
because in in my
view like what is happiness you know
like like let's say hypothetically if I
was happy like uh I I would imagine that
that is
is would be to be
content and it follows to me that to be
content is dangerously close to Lazy oh
wow yeah like like what's happiness
going to get me like where where there's
no you know and like and and and my
reality of being just like I'm not okay
like everything if even if I'm okay
right now like man I'm gonna be screwed
I'm gonna lose everything like I'm not
GNA be okay I've got to frantically
hurry up and hustle and try to do
something to make it so that I'll be
okay and and that that is effectively
like the fire under my ass you're Afra
of losing you want makes me strive and
like like it it's because I'm so
palpably uncomfortable all the time that
that I work so hard and and that I
strive so much it's hard to know the
difference though I know what you mean
cuz when I'm lit up and motivated to
write something it's a great feeling but
it's hard to know how much we're
unconsciously ritualistically reenacting
familiar traumas going like right I'm
comfortable being uncomfortable the
first time I got stoned it made me so
relaxed it freaked me out I was 28 years
old and I was like I had to find
something to worry about before I could
fall asleep and that was my first little
Glimpse that I was like this isn't the
healthiest paradigm it did drive me and
I created a lot of stuff and I'm glad
that I did but at a certain point I want
to put this to you to see what you think
I'm a huge
uh lover I didn't want to say fan but
rert Spyro wrote this book called you
are the happiness you seek right okay so
it's really looking at the question of
what is happiness and he's again I think
making the very compelling argument that
this neutral spacious field of awareness
that we are is for lack of a better word
happy it's it is H like you are
happiness and when something good
happens to
you uh he uses the example of he gave
his son a gift and it made him happy but
what he thinks is happening then is and
this is very Buddhist when you get the
thing you want for that brief moment
you're no longer striving meaning you're
no longer resisting you're no longer
averse to your reality so you settle
down and all of this clinging and
raction and aversions they go away cuz
you have the thing but when they go away
your real nature which is spacious
happiness is revealed So when you say
like it's all [__] I'm I'm barreling
towards a time when steil won't be able
to achieve and won't be able to be
praised and that's all true but the good
news is that that innate happiness that
you are will be with you then and we
should be practicing on how to dip into
that rather than looking for the next
gift the next present the next hit right
again
Buddhism Buddhism is
uh
the where you get the the idea that all
suffering comes from craving yeah no
matter what your situation is you want
it to be better if you're in pain you
want the pain just to uh lessen if
you're in pleasure you want it to you
want it to last longer to so that's why
that that phenomenon of craving and this
and the craving being the source of all
suffering is
precisely why I'm able to take a
absolutely wonderful circumstance and be
miserable in it yeah because I want it
to improve I want and then the practice
because I relate to what you're saying I
can do that too is learning to say yes
to what is and we can we can do that
right now it's it's it's hard because
like I want this podcast has to go well
and after this I have to get across town
all that stuff but it's like
surrendering Byron Katie calls it the
thought that kicks you out of heaven
right so you're in a hammock and it's
Sunset and it's perfect temperature and
you think be great if I had a nice te
and that's the thought that's the
thought that kicks you out of heaven so
the
practice that I'm working on that seems
like like it might be interesting to you
is and I always use traffic as an
example instead of postponing your
happiness to when you arrive how many
times have you arrived you know what I
mean how many times have you gotten to
the thing and did the thing and you
you're done with the thing and none of
it worked yet we keep thinking if I just
arrive on time and if I do the thing and
they say the thing I'll be happy all of
this is going you are made of peace and
all of this clinging and striving and
resisting and avering and is keep
keeping you from your state and even as
we're talking about it I'm like it's
true this isn't just a thought
experiment I when I'm in a uncomfortable
situation I ask myself is the part of me
that knows my experience The Knowing
part of me does it need anything and
it's it's always okay so if I'm trying
to
like move myself to that instead of Pete
Pete will never be okay Steve we've done
700 episodes of this podcast have you
really well what the [__] dude like so I
like having a thing to do and that's all
fine that's over on this plane but like
the real game is eart tole says how you
feel right now is how you feel about
your life so how you feel right now this
is that's all that that's all that is
and when you and the other thing that
came to mind is when they would ask
ramas are you happy he would he' look
around and go yeah I'm happy he's
looking around romdas for the feeling of
Happy he goes are you sad and he's like
yeah I'm sad are you angry yeah I'm who
can't find it it's in there it's all in
there but the thing that's looking for
those
feelings is okay yeah I mean like I uh I
agree with all of that I think that at
the same time as you know I I I do
genuinely believe that objectively if I
could choose being cont
or you know this constant state of of
I'm not okay like I there's something
really really appealing about the hustle
that comes from feeling like I'm not
okay yeah like I CH I want you to know I
completely understand look at my life
yeah I love all this stuff and I love
banging out of scripts sending I'm
waiting right now I'm hoping when we're
done with this conversation I have the
email that says I love it no notes yeah
this is ready let's go right and it's
fun to go to bargaining it's just when
it stops working for you and it will
right and that's the thing too we need
to be ready yeah like I I choose the
hustle I love the Hustle but at the same
time I I I get to a point where I have
to recognize that uh that forcing and
pushing and trying to will something to
happen that's not supposed to happen
right isn't that's not hustling that's
that's uh well when does it become a
compulsion and when does it become
illness like a mental illness I I think
I probably growing up in this
culture I think there are a lot of
civilizations throughout time that would
think both you and I even sitting here
calmly are deeply mentally ill
100% And they're right and they're right
they're they're they're absolutely right
you know um that like uh I here I am
extolling the virtue of deep unhappiness
for its results right yeah how many
people are absolutely mentally
ill this is the cop who who says he's
going to retire like someday we'll be
happy someday we'll hang it up someday
we'll stop seeking approval from
strangers and all that stuff but like
there is no day they'll just be your
last day
yeah yeah I mean I I'm hoping that um
you know my lady and I we uh we we
bought a ranch in Tennessee like uh I I
I love fantasizing about uh
us growing our own food yeah you know
like uh they just kind of living there
like and and I'm actually going to be in
Tennessee for for like the whole month
of December Knoxville Tennessee um north
of Nashville okay yeah Knoxville
Tennessee is not a place is it it is oh
oh right you got it is that is that
where he's from
I thought it was I thought I was making
a clever joke that just is a
place yeah
noo that's why that's so familiar I'm
nville um but uh but the trick is yeah
like I mean I don't know like I don't
know what it's going to be like to try
and not do anything I mean of course I'm
not going to try to not do anything but
I'm going to strive to do less yeah well
the the the only all the spiritual
things point it's just now
yeah so I'm inviting both of
us to in our right here yeah have that
ranch feeling as you drive away from the
podcast you know what I mean instead of
the ego will always choose a journey
over a destination right so it's like if
only we can get there just be there
right now I don't mean delude yourself
and say you're at the ranch but right I
think whatever I'm seeking be spacious
inside yeah cling to things a little
less tightly inside and now you're at a
ranch what is a ranch but a space why do
we love views un unobstructed views and
Vistas and and ranches is because it
reminds us of our own ability to be
spacious inside you know when you feel
tight and everything's you're wrestling
with everything when you have a negative
feeling one of the great techniques that
my wife has helped me with is like give
it space and see that it's not the whole
thing you can have that red ball of
flame and you're in it but like give it
a little step back a little bit try to
see its Dimension and its size and see
that it's a phenomenon that's existing
in you it isn't you spacious Ranch yeah
Vista View I love that I I love that and
and and it it it reminds me too of all
the people who uh went to like
India for some spiritual thing and it's
like you really didn't have to travel
all the way to India like we're in India
right now there is no India the space
that's in this room is the same space
that's outside of Jupiter you know what
I mean it's and we get trapped in this
you ever been really stone I have and
you're walking and you get the distinct
Sensation that you're you're not you're
not moving towards the bakery the bakery
is just coming towards you cuz your feet
are moving it's almost like a treadmill
it's a very Stone feeling but the reason
why that's true in a sense is that you
are always and only and ever here and
you're only and always ever now and
things just kind of travel through this
still point that never is really moving
I've had that feeling you fly somewhere
crazy and wherever you go there you are
you're just like [__] it doesn't matter
I feel that way when I look at pictures
of distant space and I'm like people are
like isn't it crazy how small we are I'm
like it's the same I am that knows
itself there that is this here it's all
it's all it's only big if you give it a
relationship do you know what I mean
nothing exists time space doesn't exist
it's just this one thing that knows
itself and you can put it anywhere and I
think a lot of the people that came back
from India were like it wasn't India it
was you the whole time right this one
thing that you can put anywhere is more
like one thing that's divided itself
into things that are everywhere that's
right in the same way R this is again
rer Spyro everybody should check him out
but he says like we're like this room he
says if you describe the contents of
this room most people would say there's
a couch there's a bigger couch there's a
backdrop there's Katie there's that but
very few people would say the space in
the room so we're like that we're these
four walls that are housing and giving a
temporary identity to this space but in
a million years none of this will be
here this space will be the same and
we're like that space you know what I'm
saying you're
housing a little block of the space and
giving the illusion that you and I are
different in the same way that the space
of this room appears to be different
from the space at the top of the Sears
Tower but it's the same space it's the
same empty space that's how we are yeah
do you want to do some
ketamine love to but I can't know I know
I know it just sounds like a ketamine
thought yeah I mean yeah ketamine's
awesome yeah you had a problem though I
mean yeah yeah I that stuff's not for it
it didn't bring out the best in me you
had wild experiences on kemy yeah I was
uh yeah I I I did I did a lot of drugs
and I lost my
license they revoked your license what
about what about anger you seem like
such a chill guy and then when I was
researching you and you
are meaning I'm not this doesn't take
that away but there are stories of like
altercations with people in the audience
and stuff is there there's a temper you
were arrested once did you attack
someone in the audience um I
didn't what happened was uh there was um
this was before I got sober too um an
audience member
like took my bottle of tequila from from
uh the stage I didn't even notice that I
only saw the bouncers going you know
handling and so I thought the bouncers
were impressive and and uh Fierce and I
said I just on a whim who wants to get
on stage and try to run past the
bouncers we'll call it British Bulldog
and it'll be great the bouncers are
going to really mess somebody
up so I orchestrated this event a coup
really yeah this this kid there's this
kid when I I was like okay you get up
here we're playing British Bulldog and
he tried to run past the bouncers and
they were like these college football
players and it was a little bit
anticlimactic they just grabbed him and
sort of as an afterthought they lifted
this kid up above their head and they
slammed him on the stage and he was like
knocked out and oh no yeah it ended up
uh it was on on camera and then then it
ended up being criminal charges and
against you yeah for this reminds me of
what they're talking about with January
6 it's like did you inite yeah is that
your fault I was a principal to second
degree battery oh wow which was a felony
and this happened in 2002 now since then
uh having a temper with um like like
performing standup of um like with with
with disruptive audience members I mean
it's a thing that we all deal with and
uh I um I think it accumulates over time
where you end up in in kind of a a straw
that broke the camel's back kind of
situation where like you know my um my
my uh ability to tolerate disruptive
audience members will will recede it'll
it'll diminish and and uh I I don't know
that that uh I I mean just I just
generally draw a pretty hard line you
know with with that I I I take the the
stance that um that it's disrespectful
to the entire audience yeah it's not
just you it's the show right and and
like I uh I'm so passionate about the
you know
the the art that I'm performing and and
the idea that you know I'm in a theater
with a thousand people who are here and
and really really this relationship
going on that's being
vandalized yeah it's vandalism yeah you
know it doesn't take any skill to key a
car just like it doesn't take any skill
to you know vandalize a a performance
yeah and so yeah like I I um have had
bouts with uh you're just not handling
that well and I don't think there's I
don't think that there's any way to
handle it well if you don't acknowledge
it then it will what do you mean you you
go harder them verbally
um yes and uh in some like just like
yeah I mean like dude you're not invited
to screw up the show you know like
you're just not like it doesn't that
sounds okay yeah yeah but I have to
imagine correct me if I'm wrong but do
the fans like this are they kind of
egging steo to be I don't think I don't
think that
um I I I don't think that there's ever a
good outcome I think that by as soon as
you acknowledge it and shut it down like
uh it's never benefited the show yeah
you know nobody like that was my
favorite part yeah nobody like it's not
like it's not awesome yeah and uh you
know if if you're if you try to be like
like gentle and delicate about it it's
not effective so in order to be
effective got to almost deplete the
energy of the of the show yes so I've
done that and then you come back to your
material and you're like why are we
listening to this guy just yelled at us
right yeah this is this is uncomfortable
right so I mean I don't know like and in
different situations I've I've been like
really aggressive like a you know like
and and and where that was
counterproductive like uh I just I don't
know it's something that that uh I
actually got into therapy for it you
know like yeah I I
literally signed up with my own promo
code for better
help to get into therapy to try to work
out like why I'm so incensed and so what
did you uncover
um I uh because you can swap therapist
at any
time promo code weird yeah right um I
mean what did I UNC like uh
I it's almost like 12-step inventory you
know like I've got unreasonable
expectations you know I've like
uh I've got uh I'm lacking compassion
you
know such an embarrassing question and
you have to be like I don't know lacking
compassion so true like it's really what
it is it's really what it is but I like
unrealistic Eddie if told me that he was
like The Four Agreements he was like
don't take it personally right and that
is like I'm taking it that's a very good
one I'm taking it personally and having
you know right right yeah and and um I
think that when I'm when I handle
heckling
the the worst when it affects me the
most I think that that really it's got a
lot less to do with the heckling and
it's got a lot more to do with yeah uh
I'm the state uncovered in you yeah and
and I'm like I said my my touring
schedule has been uh unhealthy at times
and this yeah yeah yeah so you're going
too hard I'm I'm burning the candle at
both ends and and if I'm you know I I
had a you know a mentor that I I did uh
inventory work with who who described
the the thing on people's desk where uh
it's like four balls and you pull you
pull back the one ball but it's
something four balls down that pops off
wow yeah so when when when I'm popping
off it's the symptom it's not the cause
like when when when when I'm really
really feeling riled up I've got to ask
myself what's underneath this yeah you
know what like what what like uh what
What's the what's the the initial ball
yeah yeah yeah yeah because the thing is
not the thing as they say in therapy the
thing is not the thing and uh and and so
yeah I think recognizing that and
looking for what the thing actually is
what is the thing I mean this this
horrible prank that you're stuck
in yeah yeah I
mean it seems like that's enough to I
wouldn't I wouldn't necessarily describe
myself as uh you know over like angry I
think that
um you know when it comes to that stuff
uh I like I I uh my only excuse is
Passion you know my only defense your
honor is Passion I'm passionate about my
art it cuts to the fully ancient Greek
jury and they're like he's innocent yeah
I mean really like you know I I'm
through and through I am a uh genuine
attention [__] I genuinely care so much
about that connection with the audience
and and the delivery of my art to the
audience that uh I do not take kindly to
that being interfered with does it why
does it feel like you're getting all set
up to do a drug like are you like this
is all set up for me to get the
attention that I need or is it more
altruistic that you're like the show is
for them what is your perspective on why
the show is
sacred I uh is it harshing your Buzz or
is it ruining something greater I I
think just ruining something greater I
mean like here's this this this great
experience you know like it it it it
follows logically that uh regardless of
how uh respectful all of the audience
members are I walk away with the same
compensation for the engagement yeah you
know nothing it nothing has any bearing
on on my financial
renumeration and so clearly what uh it's
not about whether I'm you know they're
not messing with my money you know like
they're just messing with the experience
right and they lose for for me like uh I
think that there like
I I I like to believe and I genuinely do
believe that there's uh some Integrity
in that that like the only thing at
stake is the experience and I I
genuinely care about the experience you
know maybe there's part of it
too that I've
got like a some kind of a a
a uh self-consciousness some kind kind
of uh of
a complex about whether I belong on that
stage and you know so like the
experience that people have when I am on
the stage is matters to me so much like
don't it's tied to your identity yeah
yeah so I mean I don't know there
there's certainly a lot there yeah
there's certainly a lot there and um and
and I really [__] care yeah yeah well
it is life or death to part of you
you're like
yeah I I really care and so um yeah you
ever seen a ghost you seem like a guy
who's seen a ghost you seen I mean I've
had uh a lot of
psychosis but have you ever seen one
that you're like I think that was a
ghost um I consider it more uh
hallucinations oh okay you know once saw
a guy uh walk through the wall and then
uh like gesture in respect to the memory
of my mother and then continue into the
living room and actually pick up my bong
and take a hit off of it and then walk
back through the
wall I mean I guess that was a
ghost or your buddy
Steve sleeping in the van in the back he
hit your bong he he lit that was the
crazy part was that I saw the bong
lifted up in the air and uh did anyone
else were you alone no no I wasone
there was a time when when uh a whole
group uh came into my apartment and and
to stage of formal
intervention and uh later it turned out
that none of them were ever there I I
literally Hall Wait did they leave at so
at the end of the intervention they were
like goodbye I think it became clear
that they weren't there like while it
was happening wow but yeah they they
they congregated and concern and this
was a drug flashback not a drug you had
taken uh that no it was while in
psychosis on you know roughly two or
three full days into cocaine Benders wow
like I was I would have been doing
cocaine staying awake for 2 to three
days and inhaling uh more nitrous oxide
than anything else wow yeah yeah and I
loved those experiences the fake
intervention yeah I mean like everything
there were a lot of like fake
interventions there were a lot of like
uh what did you love about it wouldn't
that be jarring that you then realize
they weren't there just that that that I
was privy to this activity from other
dimensions was
so you know that like that like I I I
had consumed enough uh chemicals for the
barriers between the veil yeah it erods
the barriers yeah and it it opens up uh
you know
other energies you know the the problem
with doing it with chemicals is that
that you invite in all frequencies so
you've got like demons and and you know
I called it demons and angels and demons
and um so it's
it's it's uh it's dangerous it's not
like healthy it's not good but man is it
wild I really I really did love it
hearing voices and and seeing all this
wild stuff happen cuz you weren't bored
is that what you loved about it like
something was happening I mean dude like
they were just like
trick I called them there were there
were demons and there were angels and
then there were like trickster Spirits
like that were would entertain me like
with unbelievable magic like the chair I
was in was just one time it erupted into
flames and the Flames weren't burning me
at all but I was just engulfed in flames
in this awesome chair just fire and it's
like man wasn't even hurting me I was
just like like uh I had this um this
skateboard was was drilled to the wall
above the door to my apartment from you
know on the inside and I had a glow GL
like a you know the the world a globe it
was the base of it was drilled to the
skateboard so the globe was protruding
like this and like the liquid Terminator
I saw my own face pushed from inside the
globe like it it just came out like and
it it was me but it was the globe and
then the glove started going like
headbanging you know like and I sitting
there watching this happen realizing how
like absurd it was and how it couldn't
be real but like checking with myself no
like it's still happening you like that
can't be real but it it's it yep not
it's it's persisting there was just a
million things like that that would
happen like you know these curtains just
like opening and closing on their own
with all these like lights flashing they
were just never there and it's all
really really incredible stuff I'm
trying to tie it to what you did with
pranks and continue to do with stunts I
mean
like this reality is
absurd and mysterious and way
stranger and it seems I'd like your
response to like all of us walking
around with belts and khakis and going
to Kinkos and making copies and and
going to a birthday party you seem to
have this like this is what Jud appow
called me just a minute ago and he said
to ask you about your feeling about that
the world is absurd and it you kind of
seem like you want us to look at it stop
denying it so a face coming through a
globe I think would be administering to
that you're like I knew it I knew this
place was [__] weird it's not clean
white kid sneakers it's a disaster and
it's wild and it's strange in that same
apartment I remember like the feeling an
undeniable presence of of of God
actually God was just in
like
uh you know in my my space I was like
okay so next I was just like okay so so
God like you know now that you're here
you know like like tell me why is the
world so [__] up and uh there was just
um there was just silence which in and
of itself was a response and that the
silence was just an indication
on some level that like I'm not meant to
understand it but everything's actually
the way it's supposed to be and it's
almost like in the silence it's
like you're not
like like don't don't ask me you know
this the world you know yeah like like
you you know not the world uh the answer
was no answer yeah the answer was no
answer and it was very powerful um
like to kind of like hey man like
is what is is you know there's simply
that there's not right or wrong there's
not good or bad there's simply what is
yeah that's Shakespeare there nothing is
good or bad but thinking makes it so
it's just what's happening right I I
really had a a
profound um experience and and
uh an adjustment of my view of the
Universe from Reading conversations with
God book
one really really love that who wrote
that uh Neil Donald Walsh okay it was on
the New York Times bestseller list for
uh almost three years really yeah I
think it's set a record wow and what is
it what is the it's a fairly implausible
premise it's a guy um uh asking God
questions and intuitively receiving
responses which he himself writes down
so he writes this whole dialog Chanel
book it's yeah it's a dialogue or was it
fiction was he saying he was doing this
he was having this conversation or he he
said that he was channeling yeah he was
intuitively receiving responses he wrote
down the entire dialogue which is wa
which is a tough pill to swallow to to
okay well you know um however almost
three years on the New York Times
bestseller list like lends some kind of
credibility to it remember did anything
striking about God come from your
reading of it for sure uh my mom had
suffered an
aneurism um on October 10th of
1998 and she survived it but um multiple
brain surgeries um she was heinously
disabled both physically and mentally
and the the five years which she
survived after this aneurism was was
just pure pure hell um she developed bed
sores and was screaming in pain and like
it was just the most awful traumatizing
thing that I've ever been through like
without anything even remotely close
close
and and I found myself very very angry
at any God that could allow for such
horrible suffering to happen to my mom
and what the book conversations with God
helped me with so much was that it
pointed to a flaw in my
thinking um my thinking was based on uh
the the erroneous belief that God was
somehow separate from my mom God over
here allowed this to happen to my mom
who's over there and that's wrong yeah
yeah yeah but the idea that we are all
God that God that that that what we are
what what all of us are um in this realm
of the relative is an exercise in the
universe experiencing itself yes and I
don't have to understand why God valued
this experience why it was important
yeah you know but the idea
that God wasn't over there and led to
happen over there but but that actually
my mom wasn't alone my mom was God my
mom was an expression of God yes so and
God was suffering with and as your mom
yeah and with and as you yeah and not
even necessarily I mean who knows maybe
it was even suffering I don't know yeah
right I don't know well that goes back
to my question of the
awareness right being okay and and uh I
I was I was deeply honored to have Neil
Donald Walsh on my podcast and and
explain all of this to him directly and
he said uh that um maybe this uh whole
this whole experience that my mom went
through was uh was was her gift to me
that's I mean like it's kind of a
stretch but but but it is true that the
story is now being heard by new people
and and we're
all I don't know you got a roll uh I
think yeah like U that that's my lady
creeping
through so I mean she she was already
allowed through with with calls but but
texts you you I just showed you how to
make it on do not distur you can add
certain people to you do not disturb but
the problem is I told we're going to get
you out of here my wife is always
replying to text threads where I'm on it
so I'm getting I think it's important
and it's just like sounds good or
something I'm like God damn it there's
not too many group texts that I'm on
with my with my fiance they're all on
mute you know how to mute a group text
that's a good one
mute them so that's the counter to to my
girl yes that's right that's right
although some of them I want anyway this
was
great uh thank you yeah thank you man do
you feel good I I do I I feel pretty
comfortable right now great yeah how you
feel how dare you ask me
that are you happy are you happy how
dare you I do want to ask the time you
laughed the hardest in your life can you
think time I laughed the hardest in my
life and that that's then we're out um
first thing coming to mind um when um my
buddy Dave England one of my jackass
castmates was on my podcast and and uh
we told the story about uh or he he told
the story about how uh he smeared poo on
the it was just really really funny like
uh a a PO smar it was a PO smar that
start that that instigated a little bit
of a of a retaliation he smeared poo on
the the stop it the director of
jackass's hotel room door handle the
then and everybody was was was drinking
and then so when the director came and
went to go into his room he had poo on
his hand none too pleased about it
Dave's poo yeah the director was none
too pleased about it and so he went
about finding out what room Dave England
was in she just knew I love an
expression like none too pleased working
it way into a poo smear story right so
the director you know and and back then
we used to share hotel rooms so it was
even easier the the director was uh led
into Dave England's room by the other
guy the other guy and he squatted over
his his suitcase trying to poop in but
he wasn't able to and then he peed he
peed he just just stood there being in
his in his suitcase both of them uh no
no no just the director peeing into Jeff
Tain or director Jeff Tain peeing into
Dave suitcase when Dave got
back Dave was was this was a bridge too
far
because because he had bought a stuffed
animal for his daughter very very young
um you know baby daughter yeah and and
the this stuffed animal had been peed on
by Jeff taine and that was not okay so
so Dave England and then this all
happened I want to say in in Paris and
like the next move was to go to
Amsterdam
uhhuh Dave
England called the
Airlines and cancelled everybody's
flights called the hotels canceled their
reservations and booked himself a flight
home he just left and and every like the
entire that was the prank no one goes
the entire production was had like all
of the flights were canceled all the
hotels were cancelled and Dave was went
back home and like I think what what was
so funny oh my God what was so funny
about it was that if Dave applied that
level of tenacity and ambition to his
life I mean he's got it you know know
he's he's just using it for prank
retaliation po it's in there yeah and
and yeah that is hilarious it's like
when I met mle crew when I was a little
kid I was uh you know I I I knew that
they were in my city because they had
the concert I called every single hotel
in the Yellow Pages asking to be put
through to a room under the name of
their manager called for hours finally
got through then this guy answers the
phone in the room and I said is that doc
McGee and he said no this is Doc's
Brother Scott who's this and and uh I
I'm like is is is mly crew there and uh
and and he said how did you get this
number and I told him I called every who
tell him the other Pages he said that is
awesome he says how' you like backstage
passes he gave me tickets in the fif
throw I went with my dad I got my
picture taken with Tommy Lee and Nikki
6 yeah October 25th of 198 7 he admired
your stockiness yeah for sure big time
he admired my stockiness and uh you know
I it was the most empowering thing like
I was I was literally 13 and I looked 11
and and uh you know Tommy Lee and Nikki
sck and and and Ever After my
dad said with every crappy report card
with every son if you would
just apply your the way that you you
know the way that you applied yourself
to meeting mly
crew you know but cut you on a Ledge I'm
doing it Dad yeah I'm doing it right but
again I can't do things that uh that I'm
not passionate about like if I am
passionate about it there's no stopping
me no stopping me about and you have the
photos to prove it yeah wow what a great
story thank you Ste thank you Pete would
you say keep it crispy try and say it in
your least Ste EV voice try and talk
from your vocal cords keep it
crispy very good all
right
you you
it it oh yeah you made it you made it
you made it oh yeah you made it you made
it you made it with all yeah you made it
you made it you made it oh yeah